good morning John this video comes in
three parts part one I'm back in my
house of course that doesn't mean that
my expensive camcorder is working again
so I'm filming on the old one it's
actually quite nice I remember it so
well all of its little buttons and
pushing pulley it's like eating a corn
dog it's all just so familiar and
wonderful but I'm glad to be back at my
house even though like a lot of stuff
isn't put back away yet and so I have to
do that today which I'm not looking
forward to
I need your book on how to organize a
home library but I needed it like
yesterday
part 2 Twitter project I know I've kind
of been reluctant to adopt Twitter the
Eco geek Twitter's been around for a
long time but it mostly just has a bunch
of stories coming off an ego geek not a
lot of stuff for me personally so I
decided to do a hank green twitter at
twitter.com/zeromd to type things like
I'm gonna be announcing both TV shows on
it I'm gonna be tweeting about things
that are probably not going to be very
interesting but I will try my darndest
to save them in interesting ways using a
hundred and forty characters or less
which is I gather what Twitter is for
but I also wanted to do a project with
this new twitter at twitter.com/zeromd
aint video I want you to give me one
sentence that you would like to see me
say in a video it can and should be as
ridiculous as possible I want to be
saying ridiculous things and if you do
this I will say that thing in a video
anything you want me to say hopefully
I'll get all of them in maybe I won't I
only have four minutes after all maybe a
work mom to a song that might be cool I
could definitely not use all of them
that way but then it would be like a
song written by Twitter which would be
weird but cool anyway part three as you
may or may not know it's Shark Week
Shark Week is the week of which
Discovery Channel says hey we're gonna
take all of our shark footage and put it
together into one week and scare the
crap out of you but you're not gonna be
able to stop watching because it's so
fantastically magnificent so like
yesterday I decided to follow suit
and do a shark truth or fail that's part
three and you're about to see it truth
or fail Shark Week edition hello this is
Hank green welcome to the shark edition
of truth or fail yeah I had a friend who
got attacked by a shark one time a
little one she's got like the coolest
car ever leave it to the Discovery
Channel to exploit our deepest fears in
the name of conservation and selling
commercial air time but love them or
hate them sharks are unquestionably
awesome creatures and I but there are a
few things that you don't know about
these majestic beasts as always it's
very simple I'm just going to read you
two facts and you're going to pick the
true one or you fail fact 1 the whale
shark is the biggest fish that has ha ha
so that was a real shark for a second
was a deal with that Jesus ok ok the
whale shark is the biggest fish that has
ever existed ok or fact - tiger sharks
will eat pretty much anything including
humans but this I think is the strangest
thing of all one was once found with
chickens in its stomach that's not the
strange part the strange part is that
they were still in their chicken coop